you
get ready one-minute chess win and win
fast
all right me next start off with c4 is
that how you went fast
all right let's build a center throw
that guy in there - why not eventually
e5 I think in a castle building a lot of
puns they are officially castled it's a
free pawn on a push
that ain't getting Queenie for mates
Rhett
where is he going I'm on the bishop rook
takes is needed
he's pinned tacked up in
peace
right I could have taken here that's me
takes back to tournament - okay - let's
see who's up here in the field
sheriff would see five no matter what
alright let's turn this age pun in there
it's open up that file inconvenience
white somehow maybe push maybe takes
maybe I leave white guessing
you know I get in Knight g4 there and
I'll take that dark square weaknesses
are they gonna give that guy up I'm not
sure what I want to do just do it with
this pawn if Bishop takes this Knight as
a monster takes here why is there not a
recapture right away what is my opponent
doing oh I think there's a disconnection
problem an internet problem there must
be that's an only move you got to take
that guy back Queen check if bishop or
queen block there's some knight move to
see to less than 10 seconds
they must be disconnected unless there's
some crazy issue on the site I've seen
that before where that looks like their
clock is ticking when really it's yours
here we go checking server I imagine
coming up I gotta check that server
there we got back to tournament they had
some connection issues apparently all
right so we're up there sixes the
vulture who this is a guy who definitely
watch out for watch out for that vulture
is this good there we go
the vulture has moved
has moved okay why not I'd have three
well let's make sure they don't get in
d5 it takes they're these pawns are very
vulnerable let's just scoop them up
Queen check I have to come back Bishop
c4 matron one
Queen here I might just want a block
yeah I'm gonna go with it
there is pond push but I'm gonna bank on
some attack against the king
with rook here happening next how do you
defend this the King has to go to d8 I
guess isn't that Queen one no she is
she's officially gone all right where is
the main
where is the main
and start
check
I came there not quite
where's that Bishop gonna go hmm I feel
like I could be doing one better
I guess stop that pond from moving all
together 24 seconds there's Queen here
okay
I have some entry point on the seventh
okay this should be winning everything
soon where's the maid I could take this
with check
something faster
I guess rookie
then to see a should be gained
back to tournament 16 somebody has 16 12
10 okay
first-place confetti that's this guy's
logo watch out
this guy is letting everybody know hey I
got first place confetti you better be
scared they doing this okay
it started with that I was ready to take
and then Queen h4 stuff let's play this
in a gambit style okay I have a center
then if it's gonna be declined context I
take here how are they going to Castle
after Bishop c5
it's gonna be tough queen is very well
centralized now he's a weak link he's
isolated I'm here with tempo the Queen
can't go too far Queen here I take in
the night here
I feel like there should be something
soon
have five and then here let's just back
up Bishop here I want to keep the
Queen's Own if the knight moves then I
have Knight see - Bishop f5 next okay
this is winning probably the queen queen
here I get the fork
let's throw this in
all right I guess we're gonna go in this
direction are we
however however let's do this Queen here
isn't this close to me
let's check still over here King us to
go back all right I'm gonna cash out
just grab that rook she's not any mate I
guess time wise it's the only other
thing back up to see a twenty seconds
could save my night okay here get to the
seventh breakdown the light square
diagonal where's this bishop even go
polish pawn push
check
no matter what then pin the bishop and
Bishop here next I guess rook here so
mate soon
really in a giant nod I should have
inserted the check first
where is the main
where is that me here here and then here
made on h3 no matter what happening soon
there we go back to trim in 31 31:28 20s
let's go okay mr. Lopez play against mr.
Lopez here white I deal with that I
meant something else I think
okay gambit mode declined to point some
pieces at the king I can take that guy
let's kick castled and before maybe at
some point throw that guy in a pin I
know why would I take there ooh I wasn't
good the Knights don't a pin I could be
in a pin - oh this has to be good I'm
winning the Queen I take the bishop and
the take on h7
here and then I'm on the night - Queen
takes bishop takes here
all right they resigned back to term at
50 oh man yes seven games in something
that's 50 all right I need a quick kill
on this Alan chess knows all about h2
tricks all right I don't want to grab
that pun all right I guess we're gonna
work with this not-so-great structure
okay no quick kills here
gotta get castled let's do this now okay
I have a really good night on this
square let's pile up on the weak link
what's she doing get out of here my
house that's the get out of my house
move come on it took forever oh that's a
free piece it's crumbling now all right
let's get rid of that night let's keep
them there now what's this night up to
he needs to get out of here so
check yet Oh 18 seconds I should be
doing something um faster words I should
be doing something faster Oh should you
is that your plan oh that was almost
adobe flash gambit
that's me back to tournament you can't
see it doesn't come up on the screen but
just popped up that right mouse-click
got me good
almost got me good it's got me good in
the past some of you will recall that
okay let's grab some space with tempo
and reroute the night here all right my
night likes that central post and he's
gonna like this central post he needs to
go though he needs to go though Bishop
h6 all right let's make sure it's
positional Town positional territory
that wasn't a good move I was already
played Bishop here who's gonna end up in
a fork get out of there Bishop here I
have it covered
want to trade my trade please Knight
here pop push might have been good can
we trade I want a good knight on e4
that's the plan
right here hitting everything okay
all right let's my king is gonna take a
hike all the way over here on the light
squares over here and then one day he
can also do what my knight could get
we're right here let's come back around
I changed my mind
hang on let me cut this off I'm gonna
make a mad dash in the other direction
right now over here now my king could
track down this pawn scooped him up come
back over here get this pawn this is the
next push
I got this guy
less than 10
keep pushing I don't need my knight he's
garbage anyway keep him in the corner
let him know he's garbage that pot no
he's garbage hang on to this other pond
it's gonna make life easier
eventually we do a little stepladder
stuff watch out for stalemates they're
down at time 488 66-56 almost at the
halfway point Roger that Roger 54 okay
I always fearful of like a quick strike
on that just trying to catch me in
pre-move mode by the only one who thinks
about that probably not I think in a
week in their position somehow I will
take that LightSquared Bishop all right
and point this right here they're gonna
grab here that can't be good
I should have just gone with that on
push
I want to get a knight right here so
let's get some support
let's hit it first pawn push double on
this file they're giving me that pun
okay gonna go for this
guess no night here's a pain how are we
doing timewise night here still then I
could take the rook I guess here Knight
here is gonna win material oh I think
that was close to winning material
okay trade rub check first and then
Bishop takes okay let's do this
18 seconds throw my night right on d5
it's gotta be really good
Oh Bishop check it's not for doing
anything get some more space for my king
come over here
and then if the rook go here they're
down
back to tournament 128 this guy needs to
slow down 128 what is he eating what is
that guy eating could somebody tell me
okay getting any quick wins I need
quicker wins where are they
all these silly positional games all
right build my Center alright let's
let's let's get on with it
all right let's push I'm enough support
okay space let's open this up right over
mm-hmm
that nights gonna be really good on that
square okay this the c6 square is
weakened okay I could have taken that
pawn definitely could have taken that
pun oh I couldn't take my pot again what
am i doing ah 22 seconds no how do I get
rid of that night
King has to defend deeply yeah that's
that's not how you do it dropping plans
he's not gonna help it's definitely not
gonna help rook to a2 is a pain Wow
Knight c3 he simply needs to go he
definitely needs to go oh man all right
sky it feels like he's playing stronger
than his raiding pawn push not even sure
what my
last move is doing I got a throwing time
burner soon rook takes Bishop takes here
with the check no no just give up that
pawn rook here that's not good
Bishop pin was there oh they're down on
time
wow I had to be a mouse artist on that
one but I wasn't really I wasn't really
that was super duper sloppy stay away
from those super duper sloppy positions
pops rates at the faster Mouse you
should be proud
wow you're really good with that Mouse
you should try working on your skill
next okay watch out for each seven
definitely watch out for that he's
around there should be seven all right I
have a ten
against that Queen I want to go to c4
anyway Queen c2 let's see
Queen c2h6 over there I could kill that
night I should have all right I'm okay
with that no I'm not okay with that
would be blundering stuff well it's not
blunder all right let's get my knight in
a good spot I could have taken another
pawn Wow how many free puns are you
gonna miss really really I want to know
how many free pawns are you gonna miss
oh definitely go with the Queen trade
I'm not material oh I don't move
15 seconds with the tricky night around
okay go go go go 12 all right just take
this pond and then give up your rook for
the night that's the plan okay he's gone
here we go entry points over here he's
fast he's very fast
you
keep going making 5 or something
okay back to tournament 168 121 112 110
ten minutes left I feel like I need
scholars main stuff that's the anti
scholars me whenever you see II 6 the
French defense
there will be no quick kills no quick
kills Bishop b5 check Castle throw my
rook on the e-file as soon as possible
ok let's see how black deals with that
Bishop takes should have maybe pinned
first take the knight take the pawn
bishop here to defend
oh oh I'm dropping this pun oh my
goodness
this is gonna be painful maybe I saw
hope take the night and then get over
here 33 seconds take the night Bishop d3
stuff Knight takes here if the knight
moves I'm setting it up
I wanna kill this night and then kill on
h7 if Queen here I take on h7 okay you
have this here I'm on h7 I'm just gonna
take dark square weaknesses I'm also
defending B - that's very convenient
the Queen has to get to f8 one of these
two I also have night here my queen
still invading Queen to h6
oh that's pinned made on h8 they gonna
move
you
dr. Turner 131 88
1:32 feel like I'm only playing for
second ah okay I need I think I need to
be paired up with that guy twice and I
need to beat him look like the scholars
made twice
that's all [ __ ] behind that's how far
beyond I think I am okay I have a super
strong center now I think III to
challenge it first was necessary but now
I have moves like this or pins are
Knights here
what about here right now and right here
is a killer that's a killer that is
officially a killing move Knight c2 the
whole farm is gone with that one right
wine has to say goodbye to the whole
farm are they gonna resign
let's take with the Queen here's still
happening mate well I have to give up
the Queen
they might resign
are they gonna resign in 25 seconds
they're going on queenside castle okay
oh okay
made on each - is it gonna happen still
a made on each - that's not happening
tonight have three guards everything no
it is happening H two strikes that's
exactly what I need a tool eight 150 to
150 seven minutes remaining
oh man and I guess we start off with d4
d4 93 feel like I need to do something
wild all right let's stop b5 let's make
black where
a little bit harder to get that one in
all right I have Eve for Bishop d3 I
guess II six to challenge my Center how
do I take probably like this I could
defend with here Knight g4 queen h5
stuff maybe what would it take that no
no no I should have gone with my knight
hits at that pond with my knight would
have been better my knight is much more
dangerous on this square let's come here
I guess late f5 it's so many things
I should just take here
clean g3r up there 27 seconds I'm not
getting any quick wins
okay then here
what about oh that's a very good move
unlike that we're going to go into a
Kenyan pond ending ah man
where they're better King position I
don't
no idea who's better in this one okay at
least I don't have that pun anymore this
is a two to one a healthy know I'm up
material I miscounted oh man you gotta
start counting better man you need to
start counting better okay they got to
push their pond this is May though they
still a pond to move just let him keep
moving and then made on the diagonal or
they're back to trim in 228 179 172 170
to 2nd place
mmm five minutes I get paired up one of
these guys okay
see five Queen c7
they're gonna move the game stakes have
been doubled are they gonna move yeah
they are moving I won't have been upset
if they didn't move like you you're
quick when I really do all right let's
let's try it
why not
let's go for it
so that night have any urge to move any
at all
any at all
might be close to doing something
dangerous
might be close getting there
they couldn't go in the corner I'm
setting it up Queen eh - I got it back
to terminal 192 48 who is feeding this
guy points he seems like he just keeps
gaining 42 my 20 oh this just keeps
putting the pressure on more pressure
let's throw an age plan around pin this
night
what about g4 let's go for pawn takes
push
let's roll my knight one
on this square okay this should be
crumbling soon this is how I need it to
be winning games whoa that's the whole
farm I'm on the queen with check and
resigned queen dat Queen to d2 matin to
threaten the Kings running away on d6
just push I guess push again carting
this squared they resign back to turn to
210 a little bit of excitement in my
voice but wow he's he's not gonna endure
300 less than 3 minutes left
come on let's roll here
all right I guess we go with this all
right this is not the correct way to
play this ship here looks good there's
severe look pretty good with the d5 to
follow that would have been painful
all right let's still try something over
here on h2 let's still try something all
right
it's not quite working but I could still
enter a position where what I'm up upon
right here got a castle King up now I
don't need to castle oh there's my check
oh he didn't call there okay let's
defend upon by moving them all right
let's try it again get back over here
this is what you meant to do keep your
king right here and not see ghosts this
game is a long long way off from being
over Forks where are they my Knights
guarding this Oh roof takes Knight rook
takes Knight would have been nice for my
opponent why am i allowing that night to
give me check okay appear double I have
a time edge that's it
position wise nothing exciting nothing
exciting anything anything back to
tournament 230 I have a lead but this
guy beat me on tiebreaks
if he wins his game he's gonna win on
tiebreaks uh Queen c2 there's only a
minute left I have to try something
sneaky this is in no way sneaky what I'm
doing okay I win the Queen is this uh is
this a threat oh really
hang on where's the Queen really take my
knight there
what about night here should went here
with check to follow
I want that Queen to get trapped I guess
here in a
night back it's the queen gonna be dead
soon know so easy my nights gonna be
dead soon yeah he's done just move them
ah I don't even know what that's doing
am I getting a bishop down material yes
I'm getting that
it'd be nice if this game had to finish
I think they're gonna just blow the
whistle on it thought yeah they're
blowing the whistle
I think it's third third place confetti
yeah I get I guess he won his game and
he beat me on tiebreaks
ah that's what it was he had more games
and 18 to 16 first break or the the
first high break who games are 20 out of
20 is fantastic
nice 298 2:30 2:30 2:15 198
he could economy
yeah you could have caught me Oh No one
quick game and that's it
alright let's close out of this